Joe Biden just warned
Israel to be careful
as they
consider invading Gaza
in response to these Hamas attacks.
You would think that Hamas
would be no match
for the much stronger Israeli military.
But what Biden is referring to
is the lessons the U.S.
learned after 9/11,
when our very powerful military
went to Afghanistan
and Iraq and spent decades
mired in warfare
with much less powerful fighters,
but crucially, fighting in cities.
This thing that is much more difficult
than any other kind of warfare.
Military analysts
told the Financial Times
that if Israeli soldiers
invade Gaza
they’re likely to find that
fighters are actually dressed
as civilians,
that weapons might be stored in mosques,
that houses will be rigged
with explosives.
And that there will be military
facilities under schools.
This will make it very difficult
to fight with militants
without inflicting
major harm on civilians.
The U.S.
got sucked into decades of endless,
unproductive urban warfare,
and they're warning Israel to be careful
as they consider their invasion strategy.
I’m going to be following this war
to try to understand it, if you want to
follow along for more.